- [Instructor] Let's look at
the heating curve for water.
A heating curve has
temperature on the y-axis.
In this case, we have
it in degrees Celsius.
And heat added on the x-axis,
let's say it's in kilojoules.
Let's say we have 18.0 grams of ice
and our goal is to
calculate the total heat
necessary to convert that 18 grams of ice
at -25 degrees Celsius to
steam at 125 degrees Celsius.
So we're starting with
ice at -25 degrees Celsius
and first we need to heat up the ice
to zero degrees Celsius, which
we know is the melting point.
So on our heating curve,
we're going from point A to point B.
To calculate the heat necessary,
we need to use the equation
Q is equal to mc delta T,
where q is the heat added,
m is the mass of the ice.
c is the specific heat of ice
and delta T is the change in temperature,
which is the final temperature
minus the initial temperature.
So we're trying to calculate q.
We know the mass of our ice is 18.0 grams.
The specific heat of ice
is 2.03 joules per gram degrees Celsius.
And for the change in temperature,
it's final minus initial.
So the final temperature
would be zero degrees Celsius,
initial is -25.
So zero minus -25 gives
us +25 degrees Celsius.
So grams will cancel out,
degrees Celsius cancels out.
And this gives us q is
equal to 9.1 times 10
to the second joules to
two significant figures
or we could also write 0.91 kilojoules.
Now that the ice is at
zero degrees Celsius,
we know what's going to melt.
So we're gonna go from point B
on the heating curve to point C.
And to calculate how much heat
is necessary to melt the ice,
we need to know the heat of fusion of ice,
which is equal to 6.01
kilojoules per mole.
So we need to figure out how
many moles of ice we have.
After starting with 18.0 grams,
we divide by the molar mass of H2O
which is 18.0 grams per mole.
And the grams will cancel
and give us one mole.
So we have 1.00 moles of ice
and we multiply that by
6.01 kilojoules per mole
and the moles cancel out
and give us 6.01 kilojoules.
Now that all the ice is
melted, we have liquid water.
And so on our heating curve,
we're gonna heat that liquid water
from zero degrees Celsius to 100 Celsius
which is the boiling point of water.
So we're going from point C to point D
on the heating curve.
To calculate the heat added,
we use the Q is equal to
mc delta T equation again.
So we're solving for Q.
The mass is still 18.0 grams
but the specific heat now,
since we have liquid water,
we need to use the specific
heat of liquid water,
which is 4.18 joules per
gram degrees Celsius.
And for the change in temperature,
the final temperature is 100.
So 100 minus zero gives
us +100 degrees Celsius.
So grams cancel out,
degrees Celsius cancels out
and we find that Q is
equal to 7.52 times 10
to the third joules, let me
just correct three there,
7.52 times 10 to the third joules,
which is equal to 7.52 kilojoules.
Once we reached a point
D in the heating curve,
we're at the boiling point of water.
So the heat that we add now is gonna go
into turning the liquid
water into gaseous water.
So going from point D to point E,
we're doing a phase change.
We need to know the heat
of vaporization of water,
and that's equal to 40.7
kilojoules per mole.
And we already know we
have one mole of H2O.
So one mole times 40.7
moles, the moles cancel
and it takes 40.7 kilojoules of energy
to convert the liquid water
in to gaseous water or steam.
Next we're gonna heat the gaseous water
from 100 degrees Celsius
to 125 degrees Celsius.
So we're going from point E to
point F on the heating curve.
And to figure out how
much heat we need to add,
we use the Q is equal to mc
delta T equation one more time.
So we're solving for Q and
we still have 18.0 grams.
This time we need to use
these specific heat of steam,
which is 1.84 joules
per gram degree Celsius.
The change in temperature
would be 125 minus 100
or +25 degrees Celsius.
So grams cancel, units cancel out
and we get Q is equal to 8.3
times 10 to the second joules
to two significant figures,
which is equal to 0.83 kilojoules.
Finally, we need to add everything up.
So going from point A to
point B in the heating curve.
So think about just the X
axis this time, all right?
So going from point A to point B,
we calculated that to be
equal to 0.91 kilojoules.
And then from point B to point C,
we calculated that to be 6.01 kilojoules.
From C to D, so this
distance here was 7.52.
From D to E, this was the big one here.
This was equal to 40.7 kilojoules.
And finally from E to F we calculated
this was equal to 0.83 kilojoules.
And when you add everything up
this is equal to 56.0 kilojoules.
So that's how much energy it takes
to convert 18.0 grams of
ice at -25 degrees Celsius
to gaseous water at 125 degrees Celsius.
Next, let's think about the slopes
of the different lines
on our heating curve.
So let's look at the
line going from B to C
and also the line going
from point D to point E.
Both of these lines
represent phase changes,
going from point B to point C
was going from a solid to a liquid
and going from point D to E
was going from a liquid to a gas.
And since the slope of both
of these lines is zero,
that means as you add heat on the x-axis,
the temperature doesn't change.
So during a phase change,
all the energy goes into disrupting
the intermolecular forces that are present
and they don't go into
increasing the temperature.
So there is no increase in temperature
during a phase change.
Think about going from point D to point E,
this was converting our liquid
water into gaseous water.
So as the heat is being added,
all that energy goes into
breaking the intermolecular forces
between water molecules and pulling apart
those liquid water molecules
and turning them into
gaseous water molecules.
So it's only after all of
the liquid water molecules
are converted into
gaseous water molecules,
that's when we see the
temperature increase again.
So talking about from point E to point F,
everything is now in the gaseous state
and then we see the
increase in temperature.
Finally, let's compare the
slope of the line from A to B
to the slope of the line from C to D.
If we look at it, the slope of the line
from A to B is a little bit steeper
than the slope of the line from C to D.
The reason for the different slopes
has to do with the
different specific heats.
From A to B, we used the
specific heat for ice
which is 2.03 joules per
gram degrees Celsius.
From C to D in our calculation,
we used the specific heat for water
which is 4.1 joules per
gram degrees Celsius.
The higher the value
for the specific heat,
the more energy it takes to raise
the temperature of a
substance by a certain amount.
So if we think about comparing these two,
let's say we try to raise the temperature
of ice by 25 degrees Celsius.
So lets think about this
distance here on the y-axis.
We would have to put in only
a small amount of energy
to get ice to increase its temperature
by 25 degrees Celsius.
We think about that same
temperature change on liquid water.
So if we tried to increase the
temperature of liquid water
by that same amount, 25 degrees,
we would have to put in more energy.
So on the x-axis, we have
to put in more energy
to accomplish the same
change in temperature.
And that's because liquid water
has a higher specific heat.
Since it might be a little bit
hard to see on that diagram,
let's think about putting some
heat into a substance here.
So I'm gonna draw a horizontal line,
and then we're trying to accomplish
a certain temperature change.
So I'll draw a vertical line.
Those two give me a line with a slope.
So let's say we're trying to accomplish
the same change in temperature.
So I'll draw this Y
distance the same as before
but we have a higher specific heat.
So it takes more energy.
Therefore this X distance
is going to increase.
And when we increase the X distance,
we see that the slope decreases.
So the greater the value
for the specific heat,
the lower the slope on the heating curve.